صباح الخير يا نادين صباح الخير يا سهام
صباح الخير يا اشرف صباح النور ازي حضرتك
بنرحب بيك معانا في صباح العربيه اهلا
وسهلا احنا كنا لسه بنسمع الاغنيه اللي
انت كنت بتغنيها في النفق وطبعا صوتك حلو
جدا وطول الوقت الناس بتتلم حواليكم
بتصورك فيديوهات وبتنتشر جدا على السوشيال
ميديا واحنا عايزين نعرف البدايه بدات
منين يعني ايه حكايه الغنى في النفق دي
هو مبدئيا حته ان انا اصلا عرفت صوتي حلو
دي كانت قصه كده ايام مسلسل رمضان كده كان
بيتعاد السنه اللي بعدها حبيشه كان في
اللي هي التتر الاغنيه بتاع على كل لون
كنت قاعد بغنيها كده بدندنها مع واحد
صاحبي والله على القهوه قال لي صوتك حلو
ومش عارف ايه وبتعرف تغني يعني تقول له
بصراحه انا عمري ما جربت بس انا مش مقتنع
باللي انت بتقوله قال لي طب انا هجيب واحد
صاحبي وهو اللي يعرفني ولا يعرفك هو اللي
هيشاهد ما بين قلت له تمام المهم جابه
وانا اقوم اول مره يعني غني بصوت عالي انا
انا نفسي اصلا انا
كنت شاق حلو يعني
انا عندي فعلا امكانيه ان انا ممكن اغني
ومش عربي بس كمان انجلش كمان اللي هو يعني
حاجه
كمان بتعلم ساعتها كنت لسه بتعلم انجلش
فاللي هو ساعدني ان انا اوفر وقت على نفسي
كمان حته تعليم انجلش بدات تغني وبعدين
رحت النفق بقى
النفق ده بالنسبه لي كنت باخده كده اللي
هو ايه منها لو الناس
في المعادي وفي نفس الوقت بتدرب اللي هو
مكان براحتي خالص وفي صدى صوت اللي هو
بيساعدني ان انا ولا اهلك الصوتي قصدي على
الاخر قال ان انا ابقى في حته مقفوله مش
عارف اعمله صح ولا غلط بس فكان بسمع صوتي
رايح جاي اللي هو تمام او صوتي بس ورد فعل
الناس ايه لما كانت بتشوفك في النفق اه في
ناس بتقف
ايه ده انت بتعمل ايه عجبهم بتقف تطلع
موبايلي يتصور طب انت عايز اسمك ايه على
الفيسبوك اسمك ايه على مش عارفه ايه مثلا
نعمل لك ايه يعمل لك فولو فين اللي بصراحه
بيبص ويمشي ايه اللي انت بتعمله ده فيه مش
فاهم اصلا انا بعمل ايه بس الاغلب يعني
بيبقى في يعني في ايجابيات كتير اللي هو
ايه مثلا حد يقف طب هات رقمك حتى انا اعرف
حد ممكن يساعدك حتى كله بيبقى حابب يساعد
كل شايف ان انا يجي مني يعني بمعنى اصح
مثلا تمام
[موسيقى]
ايه رايك يا نادين يسلم هالصوت سلميلنا
على اشرف يا ندى بس انا كنت حابه اشوفك
كمان بالنفق ولا ما فيش ارسال في النفق
اه للاسف طبعا تحت الارض بيكون النتورك
صعبه جدا اوكي طيب هيك طمنتيني انه هذا هو
السبب بس احنا كمان ابسطتونا واسعدتونا
واطربتونا على الصبح شكرا جزيلا والى
اللقاء